[Musique]
comme quoi
les fous de bassan se passe de
présentation
avec leur tête unique on les reconnaît à
cent lieues
depuis le temps qu'on les visites il
faut dire qu'on a appris à les connaître
mais on ne sait pas tout
aujourd'hui on vous entraîne au delà des
zones réservées aux touristes sur la
trace de chercheurs intéressés par ce
qui se passe avec les oiseaux uni mais
surtout en main
[Musique]
chaque jour pauline marty ni ses
complices de terrain les à audrix et
laura prennent le large une traversée de
15 minutes qui des maine montparnasse
ionale de l'île bonaventure et du rocher
percé
elle débarque pour leur rendez vous
quotidien avec leurs fous de bassan
ballin et doctorante en biologie à
l'université du québec à rimouski sous
la supervision de magella guillemette
son premier contact avec la colonie
d'oiseaux de lille remonte à l'an passé
on voir autant d'oiseaux réunis en un
même endroit c'est assez spectaculaire
moi j'en revenais passé c'est un très
beau spectacle
chaque jour là je m'en lasse pas
[Musique]
sur l'île au delà de 100 mille foot
bassin vent et viennent uni tout en
bavardant
pauline et ses assistantes de terrain
les rejoigne après 45 minutes de marche
on est en pleine période d'incubation
la routine du jour commence par le
décompte des oeufs des poussins
[Applaudissements]
des sites numérotée construit depuis des
années
[Musique]
pour arriver à faire le décompte on
utilise une arme redoutable un pistolet
à eau
le temps d'un léger battement d'aile
pour se débarrasser de l'eau sur son
plumage et du coup on peut voir ce que
couvre de l'oiseau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le maintien des colonies des pentes son
taux de reproduction il équivaut au
nombre de poussins qui prennent leur
envol à l'automne versus le nombre de
points de vue
jusqu'au milieu des années 2000 le taux
de reproduction des pinces les 65% un
ton jugé favorable renouvellement de la
colonie
mais à partir de 2009 le taux de
reproduction planche le cru est atteint
en 2012 à 2,7 pour cent avant de
remonter graduellement par la suite
jusqu'à atteindre autour de 50% en 2020
un des facteurs en cause la moins grande
abondance de nourriture à proximité de
la colonie attribué à nantua la surpêche
à la compétition pour les proies ou
changement température de l'eau
[Musique]
depuis 2008 on scrute le contenu de la
régurgitation des oiseaux pour analyser
ce qu'il mange ont marqué ce qu'on voit
donc si on voit des têtes des pneus ou
des contrées en nattes et
l'état de digestion de course ça peut
être un pour un poisson tout frais tout
beau jusqu'à 3 4 comme là où on a du mal
à discerner
les espèces de poissons pêchés au menu
macule arenc à plein l'encens et même du
sébaste qu'on voit de plus en plus
apparaître dans son régime alimentaire
[Musique]
on a déjà pas mal de régurgitation à peu
près 80 et la plupart c'était du capelan
on a aussi un peu de maquereaux david
belt hidoussi doctorat en biologie à
l'université du québec à rimouski
lui pauline travaillent sur des projets
conjoints
sont encore assez proche des côtes donc
de la colonie autour de l'île
bonaventure
depuis 2012 le laboratoire
d'ornithologie malines 2 et mousse qui
documentent aussi nos parcours de pêche
des fous de bassan une 150 oiseaux en
transporter des conciliateurs de données
gps j'ai posé que le gps sur l'accueil
sans appareil qui pèse une trentaine de
grammes seulement
les données gps montre avec les ans que
le foot bassin indus largement étendre
son territoire de pêche
des maritimes au labrador et même
jusqu'à tadoussac
anciennement on avait les bassins qui
s'alimentait dans un rayon d'environ 180
200 km autour de l'île bonaventure
maintenant leurs rayons il ya doublé y
ait plus que doublé en fait on a ainsi
pu établir certains liens entre la
distance parcourue pour s'alimenter et
les échecs de reproduction
souvent la conséquence de cet échec le
site souvent que les parents vont
abandonner leurs jeunes pendant trop
longtemps le jeune l'essai lui-même mais
il peut il peut mourir à cause de
l'attaqué admettons des autres
congénères des voisins et tous
[Musique]
plus voyager non plus la demande
énergétique est grande plus l'oiseau
doit se ravitailler en route
donc on n'a pas accès à tous les autres
rr toutes les autres haltes qui est fait
puisque on va aller chercher nos c'est
dans chacun de ses haltes la caisse qui
a été pêché
c'est pourquoi on teste depuis l'an
dernier l'ajout de nouveaux appareils
sur quelques oiseaux
[Applaudissements]
les oiseaux choisissent ont capturé un
ac pendant qu'il est immobilisé au sol
léa montent la garde
le chantre protéger le petit poussin
est essayé d'attaquer le pouce elle
aussi ses oeuvres
à la patenée fous de bassan on fixe un
consignataire de plongée pour mesurer la
fréquence et la profondeur des plongées
sur le dos pauline installe une caméra
elle permettra de voir ce que l'oiseau
pêche
l'appareil va se déclencher au contact
de l'eau salée
on va passer la caméra assez bas sur le
doigt ce niveau-là à peu près pour
maintenant le centre de gravité l'oiseau
la caméra demeure quelques jours sur
l'oiseau avant d'être récupéré la
lentille se trouve à cet endroit donc
dans tous les cas pendants du projet sa
filmographie dans la plongée
leur balle relâchée 70
ont placé le nid d'oiseau avec le
poussant
[Applaudissements]
un peu notre assistant de laboratoire à
nous donc on l'équipe de ces différents
types d'appareils et lui va collecter
plan d'information pour nous qu'on a
juste à récupérer après et à traiter
pour la suite
[Musique]
mais ces appareils dont la caméra sont
mises à rude épreuve
le fou qui cloue à environ 100 km à 9
les images captées par les fous plutôt
de la sensation d'être à leur place
qui on voit très clairement les poissons
les bancs de poissons ou à d'autres fous
de bassan plongée ou alors d'autres
espèces d'oiseaux marins notamment donc
des images assez impressionnante surtout
qu'on les voit pour la première fois
[Musique]
le problème c'est que le fou de bassan
n'est pas un caméraman les images
d'intérêt sont furtive et dissimulés
dans des heures de vidéo les dénicher
peut demander beaucoup de temps c'est un
peu comme ça qu'on a décidé de
développer un outil a fait l'analyse de
ces images de un outil qui nous
permettrait d'accélérer ce processus
d'analysé d'image par la reconnaissance
des espèces de poissons sont ou qui sont
captés à fait par les images vidéo
olivier nucléaire a hérité de la tâche
il est du centre de développement et de
recherche en intelligence numérique
infinie au cégep de matane
son premier défi montrent une banque
d'image des droits du foot bassin dans
différents contextes pour apprendre le
système à les reconnaître
sauf que les images originales qu'on
trouvait sur la glace ça nous aide pas
taxe dont on va le reconnaître in situ
dans leur situation de vie dans leur
milieu de vie l'enjeu ensuite de les
localiser dans la séquence vidéo et de
les classifier maj bouge énormément
souvent le poisson va devoir suspendre
un trentième de seconde donc c'est
extrêmement difficile elles prennent pas
la pause et c'est beaucoup de mouvement
on a pas d'éclairage
les images sont parfois sambre à foix
obstrué
[Musique]
la tâche est complexe et le système a
encore des ratés mais il a le mérite
pour l'instant d'identifier les
séquences d'intérêt
si l'oiseau sur l'eau pendant une heure
à la 42e minute et plonge pendant 10
secondes mais c'est tout une aiguille
dans une botte de foin par rapport à une
banque de données vidéo donc la gueule
va servir à l'idée avec l'ensemble de
ses appareils
ces dérivés repositionner dans l'espace
et dans le temps le poisson qu'ils
constituent le régime alimentaire du
foot bassin
si tout va bien on comptait une
soixantaine de déploiement caméra sur
les oiseaux cette année le travail sur
le terrain glisse poursuite jusqu'à
l'envol des nouveau nés on sait tous les
événements entre guillemets qu'ils ont
traversé au cours de la saison et on
aimerait savoir la suite après vous
donne évidemment une enfant migration
vont dans tous les cas on ne connaîtra
pas la suite mais mais un petit
pincement au coeur aussi de partir après
tout ce temps parce qu'on est attaché à
ce qu'on fait notre travail aussi et
puis aux différences individus qu'on
côtoie chaque jour la suite des choses
pour la colonie tout bassin dépendra
aussi de sa formidable capacité
d'adaptation
je pense moi c'est un espace qui carmen
brésilien sorti des changements
importants surviennent alkos tamarins
est justement
en automne encore en deux les fous de
bassan nous tiennent aussi on fait des
changements qui surviennent dans le
saint laurent
[Musique]